IMPOSE, URGING CONGRESS TO
IMPOSE STRICTER REGULATIONS ON
THE LOGGING INDUSTRY.
SHE'S JOINING US NOW FROM
KETCHUM, IDAHO.
CAROL KING, WELCOME TO THE
PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU BACK.
>> YEAH, WELL, IT'S GREAT TO BE
TALKING TO YOU.
THAT AMAZING CLIP THAT WE
PLAYED IS WHAT'S KIND OF ALMOST
EVERYBODY KNOWS.
NO ONE REALLY HAS FOCUSED IN
TERMS OF POP CULTURE OR MASS
CULTURE ON WHAT YOU DID TO TAKE
OFF TO WHERE YOU ARE RIGHT NOW
IN THE 70S, AND DEVOTE SO MUCH
OF YOUR LIFE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT.
WHAT PROMPTED YOU TO DO THAT?
>> WELL, I LIVE IN IDAHO, I
MOVED TO THIS DAY IN 1977, AND
FOR 38 YEARS, A FOREST WAS MY
NEAREST NEIGHBOR.
SO, I GOT INVOLVED WHEN I
REALIZED THAT THE EXTENT OF THE
LOGGING IS MUCH MORE THAN
PEOPLE NOW.
IN THIS TIME, WHEN SO MANY
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE,
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT
LOGGING IN THE UNITED STATES
AMID AN AMOUNT OF CARBON
COMPARABLE TO BURNING COAL IN
THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S ANNUAL, IT'S A COMPARABLE
AMOUNT.
LOGGING IS REALLY A BIG
PROBLEM.
WE SUBSIDIZE IT.
SO, WHEN WE'RE ASKING OTHER
COUNTRIES TO STOP DEFORESTATION,
HOW CAN WE DO THAT CREDIBLY
WHEN WE'RE NOT ONLY ALLOWING IN
OUR NATIONAL FORESTS, WERE
SUBSIDIZING IT?
>> WHITE REACTION HAVE YOU HAD
WHEN YOU GO TO, YOU KNOW,
CONGRESS AND OTHER OFFICIAL
PLACES TO TRY TO, YOU KNOW,
INFLUENCE THEM TO ACTUALLY STOP
IT?
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY RIGHT,
DEFORESTATION IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST THREATS TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL, I HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR A SPECIFIC BILL, THE
NORTHERN ROCKIES PROTECTION ACT,
WHICH DOES WHAT IT SAYS IT DOES,
WE CALL IT REAP UP I IT'S OUR
CRIME.
CONGRESS HAS BEEN VERY
RECEPTIVE, BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
NOT RECEPTIVE ENOUGH TO PASS
IT.
AT ONE POINT, WE HAD 188
BIPARTISAN COSPONSORS IN THE
HOUSE.
NOW THERE IS A BILL IN THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
ABSENT THIS BILL, WHAT'S GOING
ON IS THAT LOGGING IS BEING
FACILITATED BY THE
ADMINISTRATIONS FOR SERVICE.
THAT HAS BEEN OVER MULTIPLE
PRESIDENTS.
THEY FACILITATE LOGGING TO THE
POINT WHERE WE'RE TOLD, OH,
IT'S FEEL REDUCTION, IT'S
WILDFIRES, IT'S VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT, ALL THE EUPHEMISMS
BOIL DOWN TO LEAVING CLEAR CUT.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING WITHOUT
THIS BILL.
SO, THE LOGGING IS ALSO NOW
MECHANIZED, IT'S NOT EVEN ABOUT
JOBS.
THEY HAVE A MACHINE CALLED THE
FILIBUSTER, THE MACHINE GRABS A
TREE, SAWS THROUGH THE BOTTOM
OF THE TREE, TAKES THE TREE TO
WHERE THE LEAVES ARE STRIPPED.
THEN IT PILES THE TREE INTO A
PILE OF LOGS, IN JUST THE TIME
IT TOOK ME TO SAY THIS.
>> SO, YOU MUST, YOU KNOW, YOU
MUST FEEL PRETTY DEVASTATED BY
THE RECENT SUPREME COURT RULING
AGAINST THE EPA, SPECIFICALLY
AGAINST THE ABILITY TO REGULATE
CARBON EMISSIONS FROM EXISTING
POWER PLANTS.
ME >> THERE IS ACTUALLY SO MUCH
DEVASTATING NEWS COMING FROM
THE SUPREME COURT LATELY.
WE HAVE A TOOL, THERE IS A TOOL
THAT I MENTIONED, IT'S THE
NREPA BILL, WHICH WOULD PROTECT
THOSE LANDS OF CONGRESS, IT
WOULD PASS IT.
I KNOW CONGRESS IS HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME RIGHT NOW
PASSING A LOT OF THINGS THAT
SHOULD BE PASSED.
THE OTHER THING IS, PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS THE ABILITY AND THE
POWER TO DAY, HE COULD SIGN AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER STOPPING
LOGGING, PAUSING IT, MORATORIUM,
WHATEVER THE LANGUAGE, STOP
LOGGING IN OUR NATIONAL
FORESTS.
THAT IS WHAT IS INCENTIVIZING
THE TIMBER COMPANIES TO LOG.
BECAUSE WE SUBSIDIZE I.
THAT IS WHY THEY LOG IN OUR
NATIONAL FOREST.
WE HELP THEM PAY FOR.
>> IF THEY DON'T LOG IN OUR
NATIONAL FOREST.
THEY STILL HAVE PLANTATIONS,
PRIVATE LANDS THAT THEY CAN USE
SO WE WOULD NOT BE WITHOUT
LUMBER.
>> --
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN CAN DO NEEDS
TO.
>> YOU OBVIOUSLY ARE CLEARLY SO
PASSIONATE, IT'S NOT, AS I SAID,
IT'S DECADES YOU'VE BEEN DOING
IT.
YOU ALSO, AS WE JUST SAW, SO
PASSIONATE IN YOUR, WORDS YOUR
MUSIC, YOUR PERFORMANCES, ARE
YOU A NATURAL ACTIVIST?
DOES IT COME NATURALLY FROM
YOUR PERFORMANCE ON STAGE TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THIS ACTUAL FIGHT
TO THE POLITICIANS ON WHERE IT
MATTERS?
I GUESS, HOW DOES EACH PART OF
YOUR LIFE AND YOUR ACTIVITIES
REFLECT ON EACH OTHER?
>> THE WORDS THAT YOU USED'S
PASSION AND CREATIVITY,
INTELLIGENCE, ARE ALL REQUIRED
TO BE --
FOR ME ANYWAY --
THAT'S WHY I APPLY TO BEING AN
ARTIST, AND BEING AN ACTIVIST,
THOSE ARE THE SAME THINGS I
APPLY.
IT WAS A CALLING.
WHEN I SAW WHAT WAS HAPPENING,
WHEN I WALKED INTO A CLEAR CUT,
I HAD THOSE EMOTIONS.
I KNOW YOU WANT TO TRANSITION
TO THE OTHER TOPIC.
I WANT TO, BUT I JUST WANT TO
ASK PEOPLE TO GO TO WHITE HOUSE
.GOV, CONTACT US, AND LET
PRESIDENT BIDEN, HE NEEDS TO DO
THIS RIGHT NOW, STOP LOGGING IN
OUR NATIONAL FORESTS.
WE ARE IN A CLIMATE CRISIS.
TRANSITIONING THAT PASSION IS
THE SAME THING THAT I --
I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT AND THEN
THINGS WHEN I WRITE ABOUT LOVE
OR BEING A FRIEND.
EVEN FUN SONGS LIKE FEELING THE
EARTH MOVE, LOCOMOTION WASN'T
MY LYRIC, IT WAS --
NATURAL WOMAN, AGAIN, WAS HIS
LYRIC.
WE BRING A SENSIBILITY TO OUR
ART AND CREATIVE WRITING.
IT'S A GOOD --
A IN EASY TRANSITION WHEN
YOU'RE PASSIONATE ABOUT A CAUSE.
MANY ARTISTS HAVE CAUSES.
>> YES, THEY ABSOLUTELY DO.
SOME OF THEM ARE NOT TAKEN AS
SERIOUSLY AS THEY WOULD LIKE TO
BE TAKEN.
CLEARLY, AGAIN, YOU HAVE DONE
SUCH A HUGE AMOUNT OF WORK ON
THIS ISSUE.
I JUST WONDER, IN IDAHO, ARE
YOU STILL PLAYING THE PIANO,
STILL WRITING?
ARE YOU WRITING ABOUT THIS, FOR
INSTANCE?
>> NO, I DON'T.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER I WROTE
SONGS ABOUT MY LOVE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
I HAVE A LESS WELL-KNOWN SONG
CALLED MORNING SUN THAT TALKS
ABOUT THE RHYTHM OF THE SEASONS.
I WAS INFLUENCED --
THERE ARE SEASONS EVERYWHERE,
BUT IN IDAHO, THEY ARE SO
DRAMATIC.
WINTER IS REALLY WINTER.
SUMMER, I GUESS, IS WHERE WE
ARE NOW.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
IT HASN'T BEEN THAT HOT.
I'M NOT WRITING NOW SO MUCH.
I'M PUTTING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
--
SO DIRE THAT I'M PUTTING MOST
OF MY ENERGY INTO TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
LOGGING, NOT JUST FOSSIL FUELS,
BUT LOGGING REALLY IS PART OF
THE PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU A QUESTION
THAT I'M INTERESTED IN.
I COULD EVEN FRAME IT IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK.
YOU HAVE REACHED A CERTAIN AGE,
EXACTLY THE SAME AGE AS MICK
JAGGER AND PAUL MCCARTNEY.
THEY ARE STILL PERFORMING LIFE.
IN 2016, YOU ARE HERE, IN
LONDON, IN HIGH PARK.
THAT WAS YOUR LAST LIVE
PERFORMANCE.
THE BRITS AND EVERYONE WHO
MANAGED TO GET TICKETS WAS
THRILLED.
AMERICANS FELT A LITTLE BIT
LEFT OUT.
WOULD YOU DO ANOTHER LIVE
PERFORMANCE?
WOULD YOU DO IT TO BENEFIT THE
ENVIRONMENT OR RAISE AWARENESS?
>> I WOULD NEVER SAY NEVER.
I AM 80 YEARS OLD.
THAT IS RIGHT, THE SAME AGE AS
PAUL MCCARTNEY IN THOSE GUYS.
GODLESS THEM.
I FEEL LIKE, I JUST FEEL THAT
THAT WAS A VERY HIGH NOTE.
I HAVE PERFORMED IN AMERICA FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS.
I DON'T THINK I OWE AMERICANS
AN APOLOGY.
I WAS REALLY HAPPY TO GO OUT ON
THAT PARTICULAR SHOW.
I THINK THAT WILL PROBABLY BE
MY LAST MAJOR LIVE PERFORMANCE.
I AM NOW SO, LIKE I SAID, THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS SO DIRE THAT
I JUST FEEL THAT WHATEVER I CAN
DO TO INFLUENCE ANYBODY, IT
COULD BE ONE PERSON WITH,
DISAPPEARANCE ON YOUR PROGRAM,
AND I'M SURE IT WILL BE A LOT
MORE.
THEY DO SOMETHING, GET IN TOUCH
WITH BIDEN, SUPPORT THE
NORTHERN ROCKIES ECOSYSTEM
PROTECTION ACT, THAT'S A THING
I CAN DO.
THAT'S WHY I'M PUTTING IN THE
ENERGY.
>> AND YOU ARE A LEGEND, IT IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE TURNED
INTO A BIG SCREEN MOVIE.
SOMEONE HE WANTS TO TAKE A
BEAUTIFUL, THE MUSICAL THAT
PLAYED IN THE UNITED STATES AND
THE UK, AND MAKE IT A BIG
MUSICAL ON THE BIG SCREEN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
AGAIN, LOOK, IT COULD BE USED
IN THE SERVICE OF YOUR GREAT
MISSION RIGHT NOW.
>> IT COULD BE.
THE MOVIE INDUSTRY, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT.
I'VE BEEN CLOSE TO IT, I WORKED
WITH PEOPLE IN IT.
THINGS TAKE HOWEVER LONG THEY
TAKE.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN THE MOVIE
WILL BE DONE.
IT HASN'T BEEN FILMED YET.
THE FACT THAT THERE WAS A PLAY
AND I DIDN'T REALLY WANT THE
PLAY TO BE MADE BECAUSE I'M
SORT OF A PRIVATE PERSON.
WHEN THEY MADE IT, THEY DID
SUCH A GOOD JOB THAT IT HAD A
SIX YEAR RUN ON BROADWAY.
I BELIEVE IT IS STILL TOURING
IN THE UNITED STATES.
I KNOW IT TOWARD AROUND THE UK,
AS WELL.
>> INDEED, INDEED.
IT IS STILL PACKING THEM IN.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, YOU
MENTIONED, WHEN I ASKED YOU
ABOUT THE SUPREME COURT, AND
YOU SAID THERE'S A WHOLE LOT
THAT HAS COME OUT OF THERE THAT
IS QUITE TROUBLING.
I'M ASSUMING YOU MEAN THE
ROLLBACK OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS WITH
THE ROE V. WADE DECISION.
I'M GONNA THROW THIS IN BECAUSE
YOU HAVE HAD TO STAND UP FOR
YOUR RIGHTS.
YOU WERE IN SOMETHING OF AN
ABUSIVE MARRIAGE, YOU DECIDED
YOU COULDN'T TALK AGAINST ABUSE
AND STILL TAKE IT.
YOU HAD TO LEAVE.
THAT PROPELLED YOU TO GO TO
IDAHO AND FALL IN LOVE WITH THE
STATE YOU ARE IN RIGHT NOW.
TALK TO ME ABOUT WOMEN'S RIGHTS,
WHETHER IT'S IN TERMS OF ABUSE,
IN TERMS OF REPRODUCTIVE
THREATS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT I DON'T CONSIDER
THAT IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN, THE
MARRIAGE WITH JERRY GOT THEM
WAS NOT THE ABUSE OF MARRIAGE.
THAT ONE WAS LATER.
THE MAN THAT ACTUALLY GOT ME TO
COME TO IDAHO.
BACK TO THE SUPREME COURT, YES,
I AM VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES AS WELL.
VOTING RIGHTS, YOU DIDN'T
MENTION, BUT OF COURSE, THEY
ARE BETTING EVERYTHING.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE THE CRUELTY
IS THE POINT.
JUST BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO
SHOW OUR POWER.
IT'S HURTING SO MANY PEOPLE.
I AM POLITICAL BEYOND JUST THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK BECAUSE I
HAVE PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE OF THE
FOREST AND I WORK WITH
ACTIVISTS, GRASSROOTS ACTIVISTS
ON THE GROUND, THAT'S WHY I GOT
INVOLVED IN THAT.
I AM POLITICALLY ACTIVE.
WHAT I BELIEVE IS THE SOLUTION,
OKAY, I'M GONNA GET VERY 30,000
FOOT HERE, BUT I AM 80.
>> GO RIGHT AHEAD.
>> THERE ARE CYCLES, THERE ARE
CYCLES.
HISTORY HAS CYCLES.
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH BAD TIMES
BEFORE.
I'M NOT SURE THEY HAVE EVER
BEEN THIS BED, IN TERMS OF THE
ABSOLUTE KNOCKING DOWN OF THE
PILLARS OF OUR DEMOCRACY, BUT I
FEEL THAT, IF EVERYBODY, AS
LIKE ONE LITTLE MOLECULE IN THE
WHOLE ORGANISM THAT IS SOCIETY,
WHICH COMPRISES SO MANY
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PEOPLE, A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING
AND DON'T HAVE TIME TO THINK
ABOUT POLITICS.
WITH POLITICS, IT'S AFFECTING
THEM.
SHOWS LIKE YOURS ARE SO
VALUABLE BECAUSE PEOPLE WATCH
THEM AND LEARN.
IT'S NOT JUST, OH, FILLING
TIME.
YOU ARE EDUCATING PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT I SEE MY ROLE AS.
EDUCATING PEOPLE ABOUT ISSUES I
KNOW ABOUT.
GET ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO GET
INVOLVED, TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES
FOR MORE THAN ONE SOURCE SO YOU
CAN MAKE AN INTELLIGENT
DECISION.
GET INVOLVED, DO IT IN A
KNOWLEDGEABLE WAY.
BAND WITH OTHER PEOPLE,
ORGANIZE AND VOTE.
THAT'S THE FOUNDATION ON WHICH
OUR FUTURE RESTS.
THE SAME THING IS TRUE ABOUT
THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
ACT.
TAKE ACTION, RIGHT TO THE
PRESIDENT, RIGHT TO THE
CONGRESS PEOPLE.
BE INVOLVED WITH MY OVERARCHING
MESSAGE TO EVERYBODY THAT IS AS
OUTRAGED AS I AM ABOUT SOME OF
THESE DECISIONS.
AND TWO PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT TO
BELIEVE THEY ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THING, I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY BELIEVE THAT.
BUT NOT EVERYBODY IS TELLING
YOU THE TRUTH.
>> CAROL KING, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AGAIN, TO REITERATE, YOU CAME
OUT AND TWEETED, DON'T DESPAIR,
ORGANIZE A